forcément être en couple ou pas bagdad
je suis la preuve vivante je suis
rarement mis en couple sur mes émissions
et à un moment donné on fait une
émission télé réalité en sachant
pertinemment nous on est entre deux
candidats téléralité maintenant on est
des professionnels on sait très bien que
pour qu'une téléréalité soir regardez
c'est du divertissement
il faut qu'ils aient des histoires de
coeur il faut qu'ils aient des disputes
donc on vous a jamais pour vous aussi
jamais forcé de faire quoi que ce soit
on n'est pas prisonnier de la production
on a le droit de faire ce qu'on veut si
demain on a envie de partir parce que ça
ne nous plaît pas on peut aimer entendu
des histoires ils ont nos passeports et
tout mais pas du tout demain je veux que
ces six études maintenant ils ont nos
passeports ici je le veux mais si je le
veux je veux je quitte le prochain alors
y'a un truc a fait énormément parler
aussi
c'est l'alcool y en alcool oui comme je
voulais dit sur le plateau il ya un
verre d'alcool par soir par conduire
maintenant à tomber les gars qui doit
être ouvert mais on manque un mec qui
sont à temps mais effectivement la
production donne un verre aux candidats
par soir ça c'est inadmissible
ensuite est désolé ensuite mais
effectivement il ya des candidats à
faire rentrer de l'alcool dont son cours
de programme la grandeur balisé mais il
servait je ferme les yeux on verra alors
je veux dire pour e.on et des
responsables on y en a on a entre 25 et
30 ans non mais on est responsable ils
veulent pas ils veulent ni n'ont pas
envie de fouiller nos valises
maintenant oui il ya eu des magnums dans
des valises des candidats beaucoup mes
fans d'amy qui a eu il ya eu quelqu'un
mais bien il ya de tout non mais on vous
le dit mathieu
alors il ya de la drogue mais alors
encore une fois de la drogue non c'est
parce que je te dis non non c'est
exactement le même discours que j'ai eue
là d'un fonctionnaire sur ce plateau
d'accord et peut-être qu'il ya de l'alc
de la drogue c'est possible d'accord moi
je vous rien n'a changé à moi je donne
un cheveu à montreuil saint-denis ne
sait jamais où on n'a pas divulgué mais
allah vous dis bien la drague mans il ya
des gens certainement qui à la rentrée
dans tout corps des mines
mais vos coordonnées et très bien il a
fait ma copie la semaine dernière non
mais non mais non parce que non je vous
dis la vérité
il ya énormément de jeunes qui regardent
et tout et oui là c'est dans une
émission
la maison d'édition chez les réalités
vous êtes filmés mais on peut pas faire
entrer des stupéfiants mais c'est
l'émission est simple complètement
condamnable mais un câlin moi j'incite
aussi puisque visiblement on parle de
harcèlement mais on va parler de drogue
moi j'incite à quiconque qui a vécu du
harcèlement d'accord ou qui a vu
quelqu'un prendre de la drogue devant
lui allait porter plainte hier et ça
pourrait nous c'est une question posée
répondez-moi flash oui oui est-ce que
vous avez déjà vu un candidat même si ça
n'est pas été amené par la prod prendre
de la drogue dans une des dix alors je
vais je vais besoin d'être connecté j'ai
jamais vu deux candidats de prendre de
cocaïne effectivement ça m'est arrivé de
voir un candidat fumer un joint
je suis encore mal d'accord voilà vous
en voulez la vraie vérité
moi je je je je vous le demande il a dit
ça fait disons alors gg je suis pas un
mec parfait loin de là mais ça fait dix
ans depuis je suis dans la qualité que
je me bats guerre contre la cocaïne
d'accord ça fait dix ans que si je vois
un candidat de télé réalité donc vous en
avez un pourquoi non si je vous bâtissez
ou avec des si on refait le monde
sinon je vois un candidat d'accord je le
dis à la production si je voyage et
aucun prêt n'est que ça oui bernard
montiel qui surfe la tête que ça non je
sa dette jeudi vous avez posé la bonne
question mais ici si si si il en a vu
vous avez forcément vu non alors la
phrase que j'ai dit oui j'ai déjà vu
wish it d'accords illicites a mal
compris le juin voilà mes dix mais j'ai
jamais vu gottesheim devant mais d'accor
gilles verdez la différence de discours
en criant aujourd'hui est incroyable
hier on gèle affirmait oui que la
production des anges fourni de la drogue
donc elle ment selon vous alors alors en
tout chaque tir et lb mais bien sûr
qu'elles vont aller pourquoi banquiers
répond vous êtes journaliste oui vous
allez faire une enquête
oui vous avez entendu quelques parts
circuler qui est arrivé ben oui soyons
la bouche dans l'apparenté n'en merengue
pour vous un métier rendell non à mon
désir est un jouet sera utilement sur ta
tombe et laisse passer à côté son
aventure donc armé mais pourquoi les
trois mentirait quoi taper mais non non
non attendez si après ça sert un
discours propre à chacun - si vous êtes
journaliste
mais j'essaie quand même de voir et
d'entendre d'essayer d'avoir vraiment
les tenants et les aboutissants d'une
histoire c'est ça votre mandature